[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
am 23 Januar 1959 starten 10 Studierende
und Absolventen des polytechnischen
Instituts das Urals in Jekaterinenburg
ein Abenteuer sie brechen zu einer Ski-
und bergsteiger-expedition in die eisige
Wildnis auf
unter ihnen sind sieben Männer und zwei
Frauen sowie ein Veteran der im Zweiten
Weltkrieg gekämpft hat und sie nun als
Wanderführer begleitet einer der
Studenten kehrt frühzeitig um weil er an
Rheuma leidet und ihm ein akuter Schub
der Krankheit die Weiterreise unmöglich
macht aber der Rest der Truppe zieht
weiter angeführt von 23-Jährigen
Ingenieurstudenten igottlauf laut den
Filmen aus der Fotokamera und
persönlichen Tagebüchern die später von
den ermitteln im Tatort gefunden wurden
schlug das Team am ersten Februar sein
Lager auf und er richtet ein großes Zelt
an den verschneiten Hängen des
schollersache dessen Name in der Sprache
des indigenen Volkes der mannsen so viel
wie toter Berg oder stillerberg bedeutet
die Gruppe wollte eigentlich von ihrem
Zielort ein Telegramm nach Hause
schicken stattdessen gilt sie bald als
vermisst als ein Suchteam ein paar
Wochen später am Berg eintraf fand man
das Expeditionszelt das gerade noch so
aus dem Schnee heraus ragte es schien
als sei es von innen aufgeschlitzt
worden am nächsten Tag wurde die erste
Leiche in der Nähe eines zedernbaums
gefunden bis alle Toten gefunden wurden
vergingen Monate
und damit willkommen zum zweiten Teil
dieser schaurigen aber waren Geschichte
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Toni Heyer
am 4 märz 1959 werden die ersten
gleichen gerichtsmedizinisch untersucht
trotz verschiedener Wunden und innerer
Verletzungen wird als Todesursache
Unterkühlung festgestellt
Teilnehmer Rustem zum Beispiel weist
Schürfwunden Schwellungen und eine
Schädelfraktur auf der Gerichtsmediziner
vermutet dass diese ihn betäubt und zu
einem schnelleren erfrieren geführt
haben könnten am 9 mai werden die Toten
aus der Schlucht untersucht und die
Ergebnisse sind schockierend ludmilas
Leiche hat keine Zunge mehr bei ihr und
einem ihrer Kameraden vielen außerdem
beide Augäpfel und Weichteilgewebe im
Gesicht beide starben an Rippenbrüchen
und inneren Blutungen bei den anderen
werden teilweise starke Kopfverletzungen
festgestellt die in Verbindung mit den
eisigen Temperaturen zum Tod geführt
haben
fest steht eins mit ihren Kopf und
inneren Verletzungen hätten sie es nie
aus eigener Kraft vom Zelt bis zum
Fundort der Leichen geschafft die
offizielle Untersuchung wird noch im Mai
1959 abgeschlossen als Todesursache
aller Opfer wird Hypothermie also
Unterkühlung angegeben aber viele Fragen
die bleiben einfach offen warum war das
Zelt von innen aufgeschlitzt wie kann es
sein dass 9 erfahrene Menschen halb
bekleidet in die tödliche kälterin woher
stammen die Verletzungen und
Verbrennungen der Expeditionsteilnehmer
an den Kleidungsstücken einiger toter
wurden radioaktive Substanzen gefunden
wie ist das zu erklären was hat es mit
den seltsamen Lichterscheinungen auf
sich von denen unter anderem Mitglieder
des Rettungsteams und Soldaten und
Bewohner einer Stadt im Gebiet des
ostoral berichteten und woher stammen
die seltsamen Lichtflecken auf den
letzten Fotos die die jungen Leute
geschossen haben welche Rolle spielte
der viel ältere und den anderen
unbekannte Veteranen und warum wurden
ein Jahr nach dem Unglück drei
hochrangige KGB generelle entlassen und
was ist das für ein Wesen das auf einem
der letzten Fotos zu sehen ist ein
humanoides Geschöpf das im tiefen Schnee
hinter einem Baum hervorkommt und in
Richtung Kamera blickt der russische
Yeti na ja ja ja ja ich glaube wir
stecken jetzt bis zum Hals in den
wildesten Spekulationen also
erstmal rausarbeiten Mirko fangen wir
doch gleich mal mit deinem Yeti Foto an
hast du es gesehen ja klar das habe ich
findet man ganz leicht im Internet falls
ihr neugierig seid macht einfach eine
Bildersuche nach jagdlauf und Yeti okay
also warte kurz ihr wisst ja dass wir es
hier nicht so mit triggerwarnungen haben
aber wenn ihr nach diesem Bild oder
überhaupt nach Bildern von der
Expedition sucht da werdet ihr neben
tollen Bildern einer Gruppe fröhlicher
junger Abenteurer auch schreckliche
Fotos von den Leichen finden wenn ihr
euch das Foto vom Yeti anseht dann
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich ziemlich
enttäuscht sein da ist halt eine
Silhouette zu sehen die in einem
verschneiten Wald hinter einem Baum
vorguckt okay wenn man an Yetis oder
Schneemenschen also ein eigentlich aus
dem Himalaya Stamm des Fabeltier glaubt
und vielleicht noch an das Monster von
Loch Ness der dann kann man da
vielleicht irgendwas drin erkennen für
alle anderen die hat er sieht es einfach
so aus als ob da irgendein Mensch steht
ja das Gesicht das ist auch nur ein
dunkler Fleck und unidentifizierbar aber
ich meine es hat auch mindestens - 20
Grad
ganz ehrlich natürlich hat man da
irgendwas im Gesicht ganz davon
abgesehen dass die Person oder das
Fabelwesen ziemlich weit vom Fotografen
entfernt ist und naja das ist mich mal
so sagen die hatten halt keine 24
Megapixel Kameras mit ki-bild
Verbesserung das ist halt ein körniges
Schwarz-Weiß-Foto von 1959 ja ich würde
sagen die Yeti Theorie die legen wir mal
zur Seite Haken das ab es gibt ja noch
genügend andere ja und von denen können
wir auch eine ganze Menge ziemlich kurz
abhandeln weil sie uns sehr weit
hergeholt vorkommen und vor allem viele
der verbleibenden Fragen nicht erklären
leg mal los Toni am spannendsten aber
leider überhaupt nicht glaubwürdig
Außerirdischer und die
Lichterscheinungen am Himmel das waren
natürlich ihre Raumschiffe nächster
Punkt ein Liebesdrama zwei Frauen und
sieben Männer das klingt nach einem
Rezept für romantische Verwicklungen
jetzt kommt zum Streit und schließlich
zum Kampf eine tolle Geschichte für eine
Verfilmung aber welches Beziehungsdrama
sollte die ganze Gruppe dazu veranlassen
dass Zelt aufzuschlitzen und auf Socken
in den Schnee zu rennen nächste Theorie
der Spion der aus der Kälte kam ein
berühmter kalter kriegsspionage Thriller
hier in der Version der Spion der in die
Kälte ging drei Mitglieder der
Expeditionen sollen laut dieser Theorie
beim KGB gewesen sein sie sollen sich am
Berg mit westlichen Geheimagenten
treffen um sie mit Falschinformationen
zu linken und mit Proben von
radioaktiven Strontium 90 zu markieren
irgendetwas geht schief die westlichen
Spione beschließen die Gruppe zu töten
sie zwingen die jungen Leute sich
auszuziehen überlassen sie dem Tod durch
Erfrieren vorher schneiden Sie Ludmilla
die Zunge heraus weil sie von allen die
vorlauteste ist naja scheint mir auch
ein bisschen weit hergeholt aber ich
habe noch eine andere Version eine
vielleicht etwas realistischere
Geschichte demnach testete die Sowjet
Armee Geheimwaffen in der Gegend und die
Gruppe wird zufällig im Zielgebiet Opfer
der Versuche das würde zumindest die
Lichterscheinungen erklären und die
Funde von Metallresten in der Gegend und
naja zumindest einige der Verletzungen
aber kaum die halbnackte Flucht aus dem
Zelt und andere Merkwürdigkeiten
andere Theorien auch die Mansen das
indigene folgt das in der Region lebt
werden gelegentlich verantwortlich
gemacht sie hätten die Gruppe getötet
weil sie einen heiligen Ort des Volkes
entweiht hätten nur in dieser Gegend gab
es keine besonders heiligen Orte
außerdem gelten die Mansen als sehr
friedfertig und weder das von innen
aufgeschlitzte Zelt noch die
Verletzungen einiger der Opfer passend
zu dieser Geschichte
Werbung du liebst Podcasts und möchtest
deine Lieblingshose auf großer Bühne
live erleben dann habe ich einen
besonderen Veranstaltungstipp für dich
dass hier and now Podcast Festival von
Seven one Audio am zweiten und dritten
september in Köln mit dabei sind
beliebte Podcast wie beste Freundinnen
Hazel und Thomas Hörerlebnis Mord auf Ex
AWF Psychologie to go 50 + 2 und viele
viele mehr es gibt Einzeltickets mit
denen du dein lieblings Podcast sehen
und Kombi und Festival Tickets um dir
mehrere Shows anzugucken und dir dein
ganz eigenes Festival-Programm
zusammenzustellen denn es gibt an zwei
Tagen mehr als 20 live Podcasts auf vier
Bühnen in der Halle Tor 2 in Köln und
draußen davor noch eine außen area mit
food Trucks mit Getränken mit Musik also
echtes Festival Feeling alle Infos zu
dem Event und auch zu den Tickets
findest du auf vier and now festival.de
Werbung Ende
es gibt heute um die 75 Theorien zu den
Ereignissen und jattlaufpass darunter
ist wirklich wildes Zeug aber auch ein
paar Theorien die mir dann doch
plausibler als die Schneemenschen
Theorie vorkommen ja vor allem eine
Erklärung ist inzwischen weitgehend
akzeptiert und diese Erklärung scheint
erstmal so offensichtlich dass man sich
fragt warum sie sich nicht viel eher
durchgesetzt hat also mit absoluter
Sicherheit wissen wir es nicht aber in
den letzten Jahren hat sich zumindest
abseits spekulativer Mystery und
verschwörungs-
eine Lawine eine der tödlichsten
Gefahren in den Bergen aber lange Zeit
hielt man eine Lawine als Ursache für
ausgeschlossen man hatte am Unglücksort
keine der typischen Spuren einer solchen
Katastrophe gefunden
außerdem hätte eine Lawine doch das Zelt
und die Wanderer mitgerissen die
Verletzungen wären massiver gewesen und
außerdem war der Hang an dem das Zelt
aufgebaut war viel zu flach die Wetter
und Schneebedingungen zur Zeit des
Unglücks die Sprachen ebenfalls gegen
diese Theorie ja genau und wie schon
gesagt das waren ja immerhin sehr
erfahrene Leute die hätten jetzt hält ja
niemals an einer Stelle aufgebaut an dir
eine Lawine drohte also doch keine
Lawine aber vielleicht ein lawinchen die
Gruppe hat eine flache Mulde am Hang
gegraben und das zählt darin aufgestellt
um es besser gegen den zu diesem
Zeitpunkt herrschen den Schneesturm zu
schützen und dann löste sich genau über
der Senke ein sogenanntes Schneebrett
vermutlich war Stelle durch die Grabung
der jungen Leute instabil geworden und
neu Schnee hatte den Druck auf die
oberhalb des Zeltes liegenden
schneemaßen verstärkt solche
Schneebrettlawinen die können auch an
Hängen mit geringer Neigung entstehen
und Sie können vergleichsweise klein
sein
andere kojakow ein junger Staatsanwalt
aus je katharinenburg der leitete 2019
eine neue Untersuchung der Ereignisse
die zu dem Schluss kam das schon ein
Schneebrett von 5 m Länge ausreichen
würde um die Verletzungen einiger der
Expeditionsteilnehmer zu erklären den
weiteren Ablauf rekonstruiert er so als
das Schnee Britt das Zelt trifft und
deshalb verschüttet riecht Panik aus der
Eingang ist blockiert in großer Eile
zerschneiden ja zerfetzen die jungen
Leute das Zelt und zwängen sich nach
draußen sie haben keinen Überblick über
die Situation können nicht erkennen dass
es nur ein kleiner lokaler Abgang war
rechnen mit weiteren Schneemassen nur
weg hier nein lass die Schuhe stehen
lass die Rucksäcke stehen lauft humpelt
schleppt euch zum nächsten Felsen oder
bergab in den Schutz des Waldes doch die
zweite die große Lawine die kommt nicht
und im finsternacht und eine
Schneesturmes finden Sie den Weg zum
Zelt nicht oder eben nicht schnell genug
es gelingt ihnen unter einer Kiefer ein
Feuer zu entfachen ein oder zwei aus der
Gruppe klettern den Baum hoch um Zweige
als Brennholz abzubrechen doch das Feuer
kann sie nicht retten juri und Georgi
sterben als erste ihre Verbrennungen
zeugen von dem verzweifelten Versuch
sich zuwärmen die anderen schneiden
ihren toten Kameraden die Kleider vom
Leib um ihre eigene unzureichende
Bekleidung zu ergänzen dann teilen Sie
sich auf ein Teil der Gruppe sucht
weiter nach dem Zelt und geht in die
Richtung der sie glauben dass es ist
sehr frieren aber bevor sie es erreicht
die restlichen vier beschließen eine
Schneehöhle zu bauen und am nächsten
Morgen weiter nach dem Zelt zu suchen in
einer Schlucht finden Sie den tiefen
Schnee den Sie dafür brauchen doch zu
ihrem Unglück liegt der Ort oberhalb
eines kleinen Baches der auch im Winter
nicht einfriert sein Wasser mit den
Schnee in den sie ihre Höhle Graben
wollten unterspült die Schneedecke
bricht ein stürzt auf das felsige
Bachbett Tonnen schwere Schneemassen
stürzen auf die jungen Leute und
verursachen die schlimmen teils
tödlichen Verletzungen die fehlende
Zunge und die fehlenden Augäpfel die
sind vermutlich auf Tierfraß und
Verwesung zurückzuführen aber was ist
mit der Radioaktivität die an einigen
Kleidungsstücken festgestellt wurde also
ich meine das war ja wohl keine
atomlawine oder so na wohl kaum aber
auch dafür gibt es Erklärungen die ohne
Yetis oder sowjetische wunderwaffentests
auskommen die Lampen nämlich die die
Expedition mit sich führte enthielten
radioaktives torium
damals ging mal mit solchen Materialien
noch etwas langsam um und da ist noch
etwas keine zwei Jahre vor dem Unglück
ist in der kerntechnischen Anlage Majak
südlich von zwettlowski ein Tank mit
radioaktiven Abfällen explodiert eine
radioaktive Wolke zog in Richtung Norden
und
Georgi der mandolinspieler hat in dieser
Anlage gearbeitet und bei den
Aufräumarbeiten geholfen ein weiteres
Mitglied der Gruppe kam aus einem Dorf
in der kontaminierten Zone die
lawinentheorie wird inzwischen von
Forschern und Experten aus anderen
Ländern unter anderem der Schweiz
gestützt also Fall gelöst schließlich
kann ja nun alles erklärt werden tja
also aus geschäftlicher Sicht ist eine
natürliche Erklärung auf jeden Fall
nicht so gut denn wie man erwarten kann
wurde das Unglück am jagdlauf passt
x-fach für Film und Literatur genutzt
2015 kam sogar ein Computerspiel dazu
heraus
hast du irgendwie eine Theorie also ich
glaube meine lieblingstheorie sind die
Aliens weil also ich glaube ganz ehrlich
daran i want to believe aber ich meine
wenn man sich die Fakten anguckt das
klingt schon sehr plausibel mit mit der
Lawine ich meine auch gerade sowas dass
die Zunge oder die Augäpfel fehlen das
hört man ja immer wieder dass Tiere das
auch fressen oder das eben durch die
Verwesung fehlt ich sehe das genauso
manchmal sind Unglücke hat einfach auch
nur Unglücke ja oder böse Zufälle oder
eine ganze Kette von bösen Zufällen es
macht halt nicht alles Sinn im Leben und
im Sterben leider auch nicht ja und
nicht immer da wo wir hin entschuldigen
suchen werden wir auch einen finden
tja so ist es leider manchmal da hast du
recht Mirko aber eins können wir euch
versprechen bald wird es hier wieder
einen klassischen True Crime Fall geben
auch wenn ich sagen muss dass ich so
Mystery Fälle echt gerne mag ja hin und
wieder kann das ganz gerne mal sein und
wenn ihr euch für weitere Details zum
Unglück kommt auf Pass interessiert kein
Problem das Internet ist voll davon es
kann halt nur ziemlich schwer sein
Fakten und Fiktion zu trennen uns haben
zwei Artikel dabei sehr geholfen der
erste heißt Hessen old Server wird
mystery and last of new yorker.com und
there nein auf BBC Punkt Co dort UK wir
hoffen euch hat die Frage gefallen wie
immer freuen wir uns wenn ihr eine
Bewertung dalasst und uns natürlich
folgt und die Glocke abonniert wir hören
uns dann schon ganz bald wieder und bis
dahin macht es gut eure Toni und euer
Mirko